joining me now House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy congressman given Omar's
past anti-semitism kind of a denier of
al-qaeda what does this tell you about
Bernie Sanders values it tells a lot cuz
the contrasts look where he was in
Minnesota you know what's happening
washing today APEC here is Bernie
he'll promote communist Cuba but he will
not praise Israel who does he want
introducing him tonight Omar Omar who
introduced a boycott divestment sanction
bill against Israel themselves that
shows that Pelosi folded to these
socialist freshmen at the beginning of
this year do you remember when a OC at
the very beginning had a meeting with
Speaker Pelosi AOC didn't weed out the
picture Pelosi did the Speaker of the
House tweeting a picture out with a
freshman she has to come to letting the
socialist takeover you see my point in
the angle tonight I mean you saw what
happened in 2016 the people wanted one
thing and a lot of the donors wanted
something else and Donald Trump said
basically I'm gonna beat the bushes the
Obamas the media Hollywood I'm gonna
take them all on because they I think
they're all destructive to America and
he clear-cut the whole field he
clear-cut the Republican the Democrat
the moderate because he was bold and he
had the energy the Democrats are in a
pickle here they're in a real pickle and
he did it with about one-third of all
the money Bloomberg has already spent
that's things no one talked it's gonna
be pressure on Bloomberg correct to get
out at fifteen oh yeah so he and Warren
are both gonna have huge pressure
brought to bear to get out I prepare by
this race after tomorrow I personally
believe beating Biden would be easier
for President Trump and I don't know
where these Democrats get behind Bernie
has a crowd Biden does not Bernie knows
what state sees in Biden does not Bernie
knows that he's running for president
not the Senate Biden does I personally
think that debate is actually really
important for the country to have
because these kids are getting taught
all about collectivism and socialism the
wonders of Sweden and in France and its
heyday and if we only did socialism
right it would be great and it's not
fair now this is what they're being
taught so it's kind of time we had this
debate once and for all and I would love
to see Bernie versus Trump debate that
the wonders of socialism versus the
power of the Trump economy I think that
necessary frankly I think it has to I
think it's something that's been brewing
for quite some time you look at what's
been happening in Congress and other
with the Democrats it's a fight about to
happen and we ought to have it but we
better make sure we win it socialism
versus freedom there's an it was an
interesting moment where Biden's
campaign manager or spokeswoman Katie
Bedingfield was asked about the Obama
endorsement and where is it ever coming
does it matter this is how she tries to
answer is the vice president
disappointed that he hasn't gotten that
sort of public show of support at this
sort of very critical point of race from
Barack Obama no of course not he said
from the outset that he didn't want it
that he didn't think that that was that
that was right and that coming out of
the gate he needed to earn this on his
own merit look at there's only four left
and he still can't decide if he's going
to endorse Joe Biden if there was any
power to that endorsement it would have
happened today it's not gonna matter
anymore and I think what you find with
Obama he sees that Bernie is gonna win
this thing that Bernie has the momentum
this is where the Democratic Party has
moved a socialist Democratic Party look
how much politics they want to play the
dirty little secret we have a
coronavirus we have government funding
that we need to fund this you know what
Nancy Pelosi the speaker did she
withheld the bill last week you know why
so the d-triple-c could run ads against
7r upon as on the current of IRS sought
fundraising appeals I don't know how
many rabbits they actually took the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee spent money went into these
seven Republican seats to campaign
against them about the coronavirus when
she's the Speaker of the House instead
of putting America first she put her
politics first and held the bill from
coming to the foot she said last week
that this is a time for the parties to
come together congressman
she is politics all the time that's
exactly what she did from the powerhouse
and think of this all those Democrats
had an opportunity last week to denounce
what Bernie said about Cuba not one of
them voted against what he said Oh
Obama he's smart he's not you know jump
on this grenade right now oh he's a but
if his policies were so smart Hillary
would have won in 2016 if they liked
Obama the man and the personalities he's
cool and he's a great campaigner and
he's you know great family I don't
the policies ended up being as popular
as the man that's not you had to have a
magic wand to have this yeah we just
needed somebody who understood the
congressman great to see you tonight
thanks so much I cannot